islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorize the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
[Music]
lgbqt
and what they stand for which is
liberalism and the two gods pain and
pleasure
other has stood by its lord allah
subhanahu wa tala the one who's created
heavens and the earth rather than
pleasing the creation brothers and
sisters i talk about this often many
many times i even talked about this to
the saudi girl our dear sister may allah
bless her a very nice sincere sister i
have a discussion with in speaker's
quran if you guys remember
and i convey the same message to her
there is one thing that we do not
understand
every single one of us
are bound to follow a religion
every single one of us are bound to
worship some sort of a creator and every
single one of us don't really have a
choice but i mean that it's more like
you know um the book or the the
the documentary consenting manufacturing
consent brothers and sisters the point
i'm trying to make here is this we think
we have choices we don't we think we
don't have a religion yes we do
we think some of us that we don't
worship a god we are all worshiping
something
the point is this are you going to
choose to worship the true creator
follow the true religion
and make the correct choice which is
pleasing to god or are you going to
follow a false deity a force way of life
and make choices that please the
creation at the cost of displeasing the
creator that is exactly what the lgbqt
extra extra letters added in there are
saying exactly brother sisters they are
literally forcing this down your throat
as one of their spokespersons in front
of mistakes and said that they are
coming for our kids i mean if you think
about it islam is a religion that's
supposed to be you know we are the ones
that you know um force our religion down
their throat when it's clearly clear in
the quran in chapter 2 5 6 in surah
baqarah there is no compulsion in
religion as muslims when we extended the
islamic empire we are not allowed to
force people into islam
we are not allowed to force them so much
so that christians and the jews
they can have their own way of life and
judge by their sharia by their law
because we are not here to shove our
religion down other people's fault but
what you see with the lgbqt community
it's that they are operating just like a
religion which they hate so much and
they want every single person or nations
to submit
even if this means they apply sanctions
literally and sanctions bronze sisters
they are trying to shove this down our
throats they are even entering the
education system all the way down to
your zebra crossing that you cross over
they want this shoved down your throat
and you have no choice
my problem is this
anyone in whatever country they live can
choose to practice what they want to
practice no problem you want to practice
homosexuality
or if it identifies as a transaction
whatever you want you can practice that
don't shove it down our throats
yeah we do not come and shove a stand
down your thoughts we share the message
you accept it or you don't that is
totally up to you and that is the beauty
of the true religion islam it's not
there to shove it down your throat it's
there for you to convey it to you and
for you to accept it or not
but whereas with your way of life you
don't want that because before it was
like accept us how we are okay no
problem
some people said no problem okay let's
accept where you are you didn't stop
there and you would never stop there
you want us
now to be like you that's what you want
and we don't want to we do not want to
we don't force you to be like us you
know when i tell you you have to accept
islam i said no so one thing i'm going
to end on i'm going to keep this very
long problem since it's very simple just
know very well that this concept of
dawah is not exclusive to islam they are
giving their tawa on a mass scale
globally globally they are giving the
tao and calling to their way and as
muslims and islam from sisters we have
to do the same unless we see our
children our generation get lost
so you better start your darwin now
because have no doubt their tawa is
booming and once again islam's point is
very clear it is forbidden in islam it
is a sin in islam it's a major sin in
islam for those who practice it also
specifically in
out in the open what you do in your
household is between you and your lord
however islam has a right to protect the
citizens as a whole as the community and
an individual's writer doesn't override
the community at large
that's exactly what support has
legislated so once again qatar has every
right to
not promote it and change its way of
life and follow god almighty allah
subhanahu wa tala the religion islam and
it makes his choices based on his
pleasure of his creator the choice is
jesus following the creation
or the creator
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh